hey guys i'm ryan right hey brandy price
we're gonna check out this video today
the Star Wars versus Star Trek epic
trailer I was reading about this on
Yahoo News entertainment section under
Will Smith's son as a liar so I was like
that sounds like a fun video let's check
it out yeah
there's some sweet would be that yes
there is great disturbance this station
is now the ultimate power in the
universe
your father's captain a starship minutes
I dare you to do better do what must
make down
do not hesitate
that ship which at scalable and advanced
weaponry is never seen a person again
we must gather with the rest of stars to
balance the terms of the next engagement
there won't be a next engagement by the
time we've gathered it'll be too late
they don't limit get out of the chair
these trailers are [ __ ] Merlion
now
this sucks
so much it's not [ __ ] it's not
[ __ ] real that's why I'm bringing
this now
those are some of the coolest [ __ ]
trailers ever [ __ ] made additi of
these videos is unbelievably brilliant
you know like sure there's some effects
they throw in there every once in a
while to make it look like they're
actually in there but other than that
it's mainly just using the actual
footage it doesn't look like a piece of
[ __ ] that made it looks legit
I like the cutting the dialogue that
they use between the different things
get out of the chair it was it wasn't
like character mashup scenes no it was
like they had a story there was an
actual story and I was thinking like if
they did a Star Wars versus Star Trek
movie this would be a perfect story
I thought it was just gonna be a
collection of cool scenes but they have
like a gripping tale going on a dark
side like it was smart to just focus on
Darth Vader and the Sith Lord rather
than just the whole Star Wars game ya
know they made like Captain Kirk believe
like that was major props to whoever the
[ __ ] these epic family Alex something I
forgot oh yeah Alex 76 or something like
that
oh okay later yeah one thing that if I
were gonna say if it was an actual
trailer there were too much information
well yeah I know but they weren't
actually if you want an actual trailer
yeah but the fact that they're doing
this kind of trick that that editing it
seemed like they they knew how to take
clips and tell it into a different story
they didn't feel trapped by what the
actual scene was you know like how they
said I'm bringing in some help and they
show Benedict Cumberbatch like that was
perfect
as I saw Star Trek - he's a very
specific villain but they managed to
make me feel like wow they're bringing
in the help like that was cool being in
a big gun bringing in the big guns the
Cumberbatch is just this voice you know
you
really need anything else other than his
intimidating voice you just kill people
like smog he was smoke yeah it's the
voice it's not really because he's a
giant dragon it's the [ __ ] voice yeah
anyway guys thank you Yahoo for telling
me this video is that if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects brandy has a channel does a
lot of independent movie reviews on
there we'll be starting up the trailer
reviews for more indie flix so check
that out and yeah how many good moves
for me you lose let's do shut up
all smeag oh I hope you read this
everyone thinks uh Smeagol poor guy I
know who's not gonna hear that guys
I hope you read this shout out hey
what's up Ryan
I love the channel I think you're funny
as hell but come man
now a co Hemi he wasn't telling me to to
ejaculate Maria is attractive well I
find her attractive
but anyways do you think spider-man
should be in the next Avengers thanks
for reading man keep up the good work
yeah it's really out of my control at
this point so sure cuz I had power
originally in this decision Marvel and
Murray is attractive she just got a
haircut looks like John Connor from
Terminator to you but Murray's good
she's good she's got a good ass even
doesn't really work out but yeah she's
got a good ass but someone doesn't work
out she's also really funny I don't know
why anyway I moved I moved summary
that's why she's not on the channel
because she ain't my neighbor anymore
and she don't drive so yeah but Paul
Smeagol me you are not a stupid fat
Hoffman egos wanna point that I know
it's me he would there's not a hobbit
what was he
you've gone I know what was he though uh
he's not a hobbit he was something
similar to a hobbit but I forgot what it
is
[ __ ] no dwarf no little man
not the racist but the [ __ ] thing that
people are gonna get mad at me about
thanks Paul Smeagol every day me up me
go oh yeah they were calling him like a
puppy speak up